[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there was chaos atop the leaderboard in
round 12 at the candidates tournament in
Berlin as eight potential challengers
gave it their all in a furious race to
the finish
Chinese superstar ding Lauren shook off
his near miss in round 11 and won
against a Carrera mamedyarov while a
sizzling Sergei Kuryakin sports Fabiano
Khurana to leap into a tie for first
it's the penultimate round in the finish
line is in sight round 13 analysis on
today in chess starts right now
[Music]
and as we begin our today in chess show
we have some breaking news there is a
result in already in round 13 and it is
a crucial result for the standings
Wesley so from the United States has
drawn against tournament leader Sergei
car yakin who now
jumps to 7 and a half points meanwhile
Fabiano Carolina's game it's still
underway I'm Jennifer Shehadeh and I'm
here with Yasir Sara Juan and we are
taking you through in this today in
chess show not only coverage of the
candidates but some other tournaments as
well but right now the penultimate round
with five people able to win it all eyes
are on that absolutely well these are
the championship rounds and rounds well
'v well round 13 pardon me let's get to
it and take a look at the pairings my
time you see that one game has already
finished so bursts are yakun
mami Dara first we shook another massive
battle one of these players have
realistic chances of the challenging
Magnus Carlsen kinda has to win today
there are some permutations where they
could draw and get there but really a
win is in the cards if they want to get
it absolutely that whoever wins will
mathematically eliminate from the
tournament their opponent and ding glare
and Vladimir Kramnik
also very important game for ding we're
in the game that everybody's looking at
right now as we come into our show it's
between Fabio and long can fabbi pull it
out and it's a very sharp position huge
battle we'll get back to that in just a
minute but right now we have grandmaster
Maurice Ashley for more on our two
leaders Kuryakin and Keira wanna well
after round 12 Caruana and my MIDI Rob
were making the case that they were the
ones who were trying to win the
tournament mat all got up ended when
they both lost and Sergey yakin left to
the top of the leaderboard and has
better tie breaks and foie gras Fabiano
Caruana
but it's still a crazy race five players
realistically within reach of possibly
winning the event but let's take a look
at the top two Sergey Kuryakin boy he
knows how to win these events the only
player in the entire field who
one of candidates and he just surged
with four wins out of six games as you
see the last one there against Caruana
himself to get to seven points he's
drawn he's now at seven and a half with
a slim lead waiting for Khurana to play
his game Khurana having defeated Leslie
so kramnik a Neronian who right now he
is playing after car yakin drew his game
against wesley sold the american player
who wasn't doing that great anyway he's
just kept car yakking at bay with that
draw but fabulous Fabi looking to win
against Aronian Aronian at the bottom of
the entire leaderboard can't even use
the word leaderboard in his case because
he's at the bottom of the standings will
he suffer some more American fans are
hoping that Fabiano is able to tighten
the screws and win yet again against
Aronian and that would vault him into
clear first once more the definite
favorite to win it all but a long way to
go and we will bring you all the action
here on today in chess Thank You Maurice
indeed a long way to go and if we're
ready should we jump into the game of
fabiana's first let's take a look at
what's at stake here yeah sorcerer match
a million dollar prize because the
candidates itself only pays a little
over 100k but what about the ultimate
prize which is the ticket to playing
against world champion Magnus Carlsen
for the championship title that pays
minimum of half a million if you're the
runner up and / 700k if you win you also
get qualification for the 2028
candidates tournament but you know the
endorsements the sponsorship for
qualifying for the World Championship
the lifetime achievement it works well
over a million dollars especially for
somebody like Bobby well without
question I mean all the payment glory
that comes with that and you were
mentioning the sponsorships and
everything it's a life changing career
achievement if you become the Challenger
and that's what everybody came to Berlin
for that first and only first prize that
comes with becoming Challenger
luli and you know the funny thing that I
just thought of is that for somebody
like Sergei Kuryakin who just played
against 9mr years ago is the prize a
little bit more muted he's already been
the Challenger right so you know this
time if you chat if you please again and
you loses again that's not as exciting
is for the other players like you really
would want another chance to try to win
but career-wise not as big that's why
I'm rooting for Fabi well it's big if
you qualify to the championship and
winner opportunity but Fabi as we've
discussed earlier in the show
unfortunately has pretty poor Chi breaks
by virtue of losing the carjacking in
her head-to-head battle so today playing
with white and Levon Aronian this really
could be a million-dollar game if he
wins it he has over 50% chance of
becoming the Challenger if he loses it
I'm sorry if he loses his out yeah if he
draws those chances are actually not bad
he needs to be creature can drown poor
game exactly with black yeah we'll look
at those pairings later but let's just
jump into what we have this is a
position that came out of a Rudy Lopez
anti martial and we really like White's
position very much at this point we saw
this move Knight h4 queen e6 and here
already there was an opportunity I think
for fabbi that involved Knight captures
g6
just eliminating this Bishop at once
Abby played a good move - I like this
move as well Bishop d3 which eyeballs
this pawn on d5 and really it's it's
tough for LaVon LaVon is in a very very
difficult spot right here and he decided
that he had to go for Bishop h5 which
provoked the move g4 and there's no
question in my mind but you can't go
back with a bishop if you go back with a
bishop Maurice and I were just looking
at that Marie said hey give me the pawn
he'll take the bishop take the knight
take on b5 take on b5 and this is a very
healthy extra pawn for white no
compensation here
and in fact White has the two bishops so
he had White House pawning compensation
so at this point after the move g4 and
this is the current situation it's going
to be a sacrifice and Knight takes chief
Knight takes g4 looks like the bet the
best way of sacrificing a piece for two
ponds will capture this Knight Bishop
takes f3 and there's a cute little trick
here you are after check it's not all
going that B's way because this King has
to find just find a square our original
thought was king h2 but Maurice pointed
out rook takes d3 Queen takes d3 Bishop
f2 even though blacks a rook down this
Knight is hanging as well as this rook
that is a variation that actually works
out quite ok for black so King g3
stopping any Bishop f2 ideas any rook
takes d3 ideas black has two pawns
White's king is a little bit exposed
that as soon as white consolidates this
insufficient compensation so we're on
pins and needles over here in st. Louis
wandering hand fabbi pulled us out how
dangerous are these sacrifices Murray's
supposed to be dangerous at all with
that Knight on f1 Knights Knights are
really good when they're close to Kings
protecting and in this case he's got two
nights hanging out over here although
this one is slightly offside not
supposed to be that dangerous but I'll
tell you in practical terms that's
probably lavon's best chance because
otherwise he's just gonna get his head
sat on I mean that's really what's about
to happen b5 is absolutely hanging it'll
just be a free pawn the most important
piece to look at as far as I'm concerned
and I've suffered with this before in
some formations is this knight on c6 the
knight is unable to get to any squares
any productive squares usually this nice
one Knight wants to swing around and get
to g6 and then possibly the f4 or even
h4 but this Knight right now is so
curtailed by this poor information this
Bishop it's got the long diagonal but it
also has no penetrating squares so the
fact that white is actually just scooped
material for no reason means that black
will not get any real counterplay in
this position so I don't see him playing
this bishop back even if he doesn't like
the look of this sacrifice Knight takes
pawn takes Bishop takes after we in this
check and as you pointed out King to g3
at least in this line maybe he can swing
start to swing his knight now and see if
he can create some kind of noise on this
side of the board and say maybe I'll
create some funky stuff this King after
all is not that secure I would think in
practical terms that LaVon might go for
this position it's it's definitely
looking worse for him materially but at
least it looks confusing in some kind of
way I don't think it works but I'm gonna
guess this I would say 50/50 chance
because everything else if you look at
it after G for something like Bishop
takes for example you could go into this
kind of position Knight takes as you're
hitting this Bishop and hitting this
pawn so that's two guys you're hitting
but the move Bishop to e2 hits the
knight directly threatening to play
Bishop takes Knight and if you now take
and get your third pawn now I can just
flick back and start talking about this
pawn over here this is another ending
that maybe LaVon might be thinking about
or he'll look at it and see the two
bishops especially this one and White's
gonna have an easy time curtailing the
Kings side and maybe he might straight
chase this for a draw as well Bobby's
gonna be happy no matter what happens
Bobby's the one now thinking about the
win we'll see whether he can pull it off
in the next several moves Wow okay well
again pins and needles over here another
crucial game that appears to be heading
for a draw that is actually not in
either player's favor is the game
between Shaq and Sasha both players
looking for a win and an opportunity to
eliminate their opponent but so far
things have been really balanced in that
game and let me just bring that up on my
board I mean both of them have minimal
chances to win with a win they would
really rock it off so one of those
situations where if you could if they
could both agree to have like a 50/50
chance of winning and make the most
lasting battle possible that will
benefit them both the chest doesn't work
like that unfortunately and in this case
there's there's been a lot of trades and
I was wondering if ye could play
something like Bishop to c6 and maybe
try to play Queen Seas
right but the problem is a move like
Bishop c6 can even if you're met by
something like it a six potentially
trading off an additional pawn it's just
one of those situations where it's queen
and night versus Queen and Bishop equal
number of pawns and it's very hard for
either player that make headway a draw
is overwhelmingly looking like the right
result of Maurice how to agree with that
yeah as in a pawn on white pawn on e5
looks like the only thing to make
progress in that position and this other
game extremely critical for the
standings especially for the fans in
China is the game between Kramnik and
ding Lauren if you are anyone in this
tournament you don't want to be playing
kramnik that's just a fact because you
never know what's going to happen and he
is playing either genius chess and
overstepping or he just blows you off
the board and in this game right here
ding Lauren having finally won yesterday
after just that critical non win against
Grizz joke what he's gonna play that
beautiful night to d8 he's gonna regret
that for a long time to come but in this
position chronically the move g5 and yes
sir you and I were looking at the very
natural just rook to d1 what else to
play pressure the pawn ding Lauren made
one waiting move h3 said let me just
stop what this guy's trying to do but
you didn't realize who he's playing it's
crowning f5 screamed on the board and
suddenly it's white who has all this
point and he captured on f5 and suddenly
after Bishop takes takes they became a
rook sacrifice on this square followed
by check to the king with the attack on
the night as well the game continued
with Queen to e4 Queen takes on a three
f e6 and now Knight f6 coming back into
the game this night and this Queen now
on this diagonal major problems he
dropped back to e2 and then check and
after I have three h5 looking to play g4
and he's got two pieces for the rook and
it looks like it's all chronic in this
position so ding Lauren in trouble he's
gonna have to see if he can come up with
some kind of defense against his black
assault if he loses his game there are
no variations no mathematical
possibilities of him winning this
tournament so he is in crisis mode right
now critical situation for ding Lauren
and it looks like
in trouble absolutely well those bite
you these are our current standing
senator great Sergey Karjakin was seven
and a half points Fabiano karana with
seven points but he does have the edge
in this game can even beat Levon Aronian
and supersede Surya cardiac and and make
+3 the score to chase for now if +3 is a
square for chase for that's gonna knock
a lot of players out that's gonna bring
ding Guren out of it even if he draws
the game I'll put three choke and mommy
daraa of almost completely out of it
right so really that plus three would be
putting the pressure on Sergei car yeah
can huge mess around yes what do you
think yes do you think that Bobby's
gonna come through for frost and win
this game for everyone oh my spidey
sense is tingling because the sir sure
feels like he's at a golden opportunity
right now I mean his position really
looks like he has a big edge and this is
just for day yes and calculation right
though yes he enjoys these very sharp
positions where his calculation ability
is really second to none and he likes it
when he has the material as well that
he's not gone overboard with the
sacrifices and stuff and for LaVon you
know it's just you know lavon's lament
you know just everything has gone wrong
for him in this tournament and he's
playing a very very very motivated
Fabiano and let me ask you variations
where you see your king you know going
to g3 feels a little scary how important
it is for players watching this to you
know keep a cool head and sometimes if
it you know analyze those variations and
say I gotta go for this I'm better right
well I mean I've been maintaining when
you're calm it's so hard because you you
know this is a really really high
pressure high stakes game but on the
other hand if you can calculate that
your king is actually safe then it's a
that then it's really really nice
let's see because we have seen the
sacrifice we anticipated on g4 but
actually a different whoops where's my
gift
Bishop takes g4 Bishop takes you for
just a second that's right yes we did
see them on no that's okay daddy have
seen Bishop takes g4 we were looking at
Knight takes d4 when you sacrifice a a
minor piece for two pawns genuine
generally speaking you're trying to
sacrifice the night and keep the bishops
in this particular case LaVon felt that
giving up the bishop capturing with the
knight army leaving the knight on the
board he's eyeballing an opportunity of
crashing through on f2 black is
threatening Knight takes up two which
would attack this bishop on d3 as well
as combine it with the offensive move
Queen h3 so this is the current position
and Fabiano to play and I don't think
time is a factor is it I think they
played there already and moved 27 and we
still have 40 minutes left in the time
control so okay it could become a factor
but you know a lot of the big
complications are behind us and so they
were gonna get down to the last few
minutes I think they and weren't
confident with law was proceeding I
think Bobby would have used it by now so
yes he must he must have felt when you
play g4 that this was pretty safe for
him okay well let's see what he has
facing okay so Knight takes f2 Bishop
takes f2 are the big threats I'm worried
about Knight takes f2 in Queen h3 this
night on h5 isn't for me this night on
h4 is not playing that greater role
let's take a look at the more most
forcing move Knight f5 now I'm opening
up an attack against the night so we're
assuming Knight takes f2 which is a pawn
number three by the way and it
simultaneously attacks the bishop the
bishop drops back to d3 and says okay
Bishop on d3 - C - you've done your
worst now deal with the fact that this
knight on f2 has the potential of
getting trapped in other words if I get
to play the move Knight e3 the knight on
f2 has no supporters
Queen g6 check but that looks like it's
it's going nowhere after this night that
can actually be useful one day having
that night on g3 as a backup yummy this
looks this looks phenomenal overweighted
well it is three pawns I just want to
emphasize that and you know
lavon's in a very very tough position
and at least he's got some very you know
counter attacking chances this the
strangest part here is that because
White's pieces in a funny way this
Bishop on d3 kind of x-rays this
diagonal miss bishop on h6 all
underneath this bishop on c1 also hit it
says h6 you've got ideas of rook h1 rook
h4 and sacrifices six that's what I was
thinking if the Queen ever moves the
knight might pop in to h5 and you're
dealing with a so it's actually white
who might end up at hacking here in the
end yeah that's really good news for
really really really good news because
if you if you have three pawns if you
have a piece pardon me you and you're
playing against the pawns and you have a
chance to go after the guys King that
extra piece is very very meaningful so
I'm looking at night of five Knight
takes f2 maybe night if she was just a
mistake I'm not sure maybe he has to
play Bishop takes f2 here
pardon me Queen takes g4 and Queen takes
g7 is checkmate
so Bishop takes f2 simply does not work
so we were looking at night up to Bishop
back to c2 and I don't see Maurice
pointed out a really nice point earlier
that was the fact that this knight on c6
is so passive the structure limits the
night I really like fabbi chances
Maurice over to you I was playing around
with the computer and I'm not feeling
good right now I have to tell you not
for the white pieces there is absolute
chaos that's possible that white will
have to
control and it looks as though black had
this minimalist possibility because he's
gotten these three pawns but he's got
one piece leading the entire show but
but they're variations that are just
simply impossible to assess really
easily and just take a look at these
guys I'm gonna go through this slowly
because I'm just mystified as I'm
looking at these variations Knight takes
on f2 your Bishop is under attack
Bishop to see to getting the bishop out
of danger and now this male moved g6
attacking the knight and trying to get
into this h3 Square where you can try to
get a little checkmate action on h1
that's possible now the engine is giving
all kinds of crazy lines here one move
is to play the move a5 to chase the
bishop backwards before playing this
move which looks like super solid Bishop
to e3 then suddenly the knight
sacrifices yet again Knight takes on e4
and when you steal the point of course
is to take on at five
note that when this file opens the King
comes under pressure so if you temporize
trying to take on e4 with and with the
Queen then he throws in this move Knight
takes on c3 and there's a bit of chaos
as you play Queen to e3 now he takes on
f5 giving away a rock in the main line
Bishop takes and now the move Knight to
d5 and after the Queen moves
efore your Bishop is trapped in the
position you're down it looks like
you're down a rook but this King is
suddenly funny and there might be some
attacking chances just trying to judge
this one it looks like white should
somehow be okay but you can't just
quickly judge it this is a really crazy
position another one that could arise is
if you try to solidify everything with
Knight - III attacking this Knight then
after takes and takes now this Knight is
under attack and so is this Queen the
problem is that after Queen to f6 Queen
takes Knight you feel like okay
everything should be alright this attack
doesn't seem serious your queen can't
leave your pieces are stuck suddenly
comes this sick move Knight takes d4
pawn takes and then rook to d4 and
suddenly rooks are streaming into the
position a route can land on f4 your
knight is pinned
what's going
on now this is all crazy computer
analysis for sure
but it turns out that LaVon has started
it all with the move g6 in the game
itself so we do have the beginning of
this insanity on the chessboard right
now now the engine thing they can tamp
down White's initiative even every
position I just showed you the engines
think that white is still better but not
like +5 when they're down a rook it's
more like +2 and when you do that it
means there's compensation on the board
and it's really hard to assess those
positions so Fabi is right now in the
lion's mouth and we'll have to figure
out how to excavate and extricate
himself from this craziness yes I don't
know what do you see how do you use all
your defensive skills to try to stop
this monster from attacking you good
point because I really I did not see
those variations at all well no I would
have double checked on g6 that move
looks basically really compelling and
I'm just you know like I would be
frightened quite frankly about the
variations that you were just talking
about Maurice you know winning a rook
but having you know a wide-open King I'm
looking for something that I can just as
you say tamp down the initiative that
black is getting if I were to drop back
with my knight Knight a5 to e3
give me this night I'm not afraid of
Queen h3 check there is Knight h3 this
night when we had kicked it back it
wasn't doing anything
now it's actually eyeballing the square
f4 again I would I would be seeking to
trade Queens getting into King safety
but after Knight f4 check again it is
three pawns already and I still well boy
I haven't I haven't solved my issues I
mean my king is still free-floating so
to speak there is the Knight d5 though
95 after that move maybe what the doctor
ordered after Knight to h3 to put the
knight on d5 instead of Queens - Knight
d5 in cement
that night on that square and now your
Bishop is in the in the act one on c1
it's going on as well and this may just
be it Wow
this this this line actually is not
complicated it's hard for black to prove
any kind of real complications and this
may be the deal
well again I'm looking for those easy
there easy to easy to play human moves
yeah because if I can just get this
night off the board this knight on h3
that's bothering if I can play Knight g3
and rook h1 I'm golden if you yesterday
that Bob you could have this position
with white you you would you would say
immediately yes absolutely no it's not
gonna be easy but this is a great golden
opportunity for him a hundred percent
agreed double edged position unlike for
example the Wesley so game where just
nothing ever develop there's just a lot
of peace trades or forget example Shaq
Jackson in must-win situation but
Richard just calmly traded everything
and it looks like an easy draw for both
players
this game is wild and whites for choice
and from a numbers perspective that's
really important for favi because he
does play black and the final round and
his chances might be covering somebody
actually did a simulation Eric I think
it was Eric on on Twitter Erin your sin
yeah Eric Isaacson actually you checked
all the different possibilities for this
tournament to conclude and there's sixty
five hundred plus alone just two rounds
to go ways okay doesn't win this game
there's there's a chances of winning you
know they might be like around twenty
twenty-five percent just because of
Serkis superior tiebreaks if he does win
this game it flips and five he's the one
who's like a 60% favorite to win the
whole thing does that puts the pressure
on Sergei to win his final round game so
I think that the the gamblers choice is
really
if you can mix it up in this game and
not only mix it up but mix it up with
the edge yeah this is a wonderful
situation for favi agreed all around and
the game is super super sharp do we have
a move after g7 yeah yeah the line it's
it's that same computer line that is now
emerging on the board and he did in fact
choose the other night to go to e3 looks
much more natural to play this move
versus the move your movie is retreating
because as you mentioned then I could go
to h3 but 95 and it's just a
straightforward simple tamping down of
the attack but this way you still have
this weird night on this square and he
must have seen this night is trapped and
so he figured this will be a good life
for him but the very natural takes takes
and then Queen to f6 okay this I say
natural of course just taking a piece as
natural but it still is leaving your
knight on f2 hanging after Queen takes
on f2 everything looks like he might
have everything under control thinking
everything's okay
until this move shows up will LaVon find
this absolutely spectacular sacrifice
with rook d4 we're still a ways away no
LaVon hasn't played I want to say many
maybe any good games in this tournament
any really good games for his quality
but if he plays like this this will be
spectacular one to remember for him at
least not before American fans this
position is amazing and I mean this this
what do you do it's a very
straightforward line after takes Queen
f6 if he if he sees the lining that is
LaVon spill has to go in there and find
this line and realize that he has this
amazing sacrifice that puts his rook on
d4 and coordinates all his pieces now it
still a ways away this position still a
ways away and to judge that all of
whites pieces are out of the action and
black is gonna swing this work into the
game he's actually down to pieces not so
easy to just judge that position but
these pieces are flooding so fast and
especially this rook at four move this
one here
with the other work showing up and
suddenly all of whites extra pieces are
simply irrelevant he doesn't find night
before how good is it for Fabi if he
doesn't find night before I'm not sure
what he could do in this position to
keep the attack going for example let's
play rook to GA check and then suddenly
the king can move King the engines
giving King h3 as the best move well in
this position
guarding on this side and suddenly you
can't build although I would say even if
I have to face this move I'd be a little
worried but but it's hard to get the
Queen out of the way and now the
sacrifices don't matter and again it's
this bad night on the square on the c6
squared I can't get into the game well I
think King h3 might be kind of important
because if you don't maybe there's some
stuff with takes on a3 and rook G for
getting your rooks into the game right
absolutely well remember I mean let's
just try and move like rook to g5 and
now the engines are going cuckoo with
the move Queen to h4 and now that the
Queen and King are defending this side
it's very hard to stop a move like night
here and the Queen's gonna have to move
and then suddenly he's getting the job
done so LaVon has to find this this line
maybe looks like it's pretty critical
that at this point I don't think Bobby
sees it now cuz if he did maybe think
longer whoa well you know be crazy yeah
but this position here LaVon is in dire
straits he's got to find some moves his
knight is under attack if his initiative
just blows up and goes away then he just
loses the game so in for a penny in for
a pound we'll see what he does in the
next two moves maybe you're a tactical
pattern do you think LaVon will find it
especially in bad form I mean this is
definitely a kind of computer move but
is it a computer move that you would
find just because process of elimination
otherwise your position is terrible
exactly well desperation breeds
creativity right and again if you we do
have this move Knight f1 III on the
board and you really just as you said
it's almost a process of elimination the
knight on f2 is trapped if you lose the
knight get no compensation your two
pieces down so you start with this move
tape
so now your piece up takes Queen f6
Queen takes now here perhaps you don't
discover this move night before because
you're not you don't realize how strong
the maneuver rook d4 to f4 is but if you
don't see night before you say how am I
gonna get this knight in the game you do
see a move for example like efore okay
the idea here is you're just giving your
knight your queen on c3 you pardon me
your queen on that six a way of getting
into the game but it's actually a very
big tempo and white has a lot of answers
Queen f4 is a very natural move you're
not really afraid I think of Queen takes
well I can I can I like start
sacrificing you have work g8 though like
I was thinking about moving my knight
away because I'm queen takes eight six
yeah right so any 5e for you start to
think about right do you think about
night before or also that's and I think
about 94 yeah 94 the thing I always
worry about is like well what if the guy
never has to take you know if he doesn't
have to take then the bishop posts up
and that's why night before so nice
could be found yeah because if you see
if you look at 94 and you realize Bishop
before then you might look at night
before exactly and you're capturing a
pond and you're threatening the bishop
on c2 and as well as 93 but it is a
remarkable position that Maurice is
forcing us to consider because you're
sitting there going hello I have two
pieces I have two pieces but then you
see this move rook rook F for you
realize how really disruptive it is I
mean you want to be able to bring your
King back to f1 but you're just walk
against a rook check putting your King
on h3 oh man that is really walking a
tightrope
Maurice look the same King safety black
is sitting behind that pawn on 86th and
also being guarded by that white pawn on
f5 as well so the black king is saying
I'm cool I'm happy here no problem yes
you're up all that material you're
actually only up one okay we know three
pawns for a piece in this position
really doesn't count because you could
probably steal all those pawns with your
pieces but you're really only up a piece
materially so just because at some point
you're gonna sacrifice back and hope
that everything's okay after you finish
sacrificing right and so we have to make
a material count at least to keep track
of what's going on so well I guess six
pawns White has three and and and now we
get back to the exposure of the King
right and it looks like it's the thing
in this position three major pieces
attacking that Bishop on d6 just
laughing right now then you look at all
the damage I'm gonna do and that pin is
nasty and we know if we took those two
bishops off white is cool and even given
the pawns white is clearly lost there's
no doubt about it
the only thing you like about whites
position is the fact that he has
material because nothing else that means
best piece is the knight only three the
most advanced piece everything else will
black just flowing this is deadly
dangerous even drawing this position any
computer right now is giving triple
zeros ah purple zeroes for this position
Wow crazy to say that at all this looks
so tricky to save with the roles of
bismi flipped complete control
now it's fabbi who has to make some
really good defensive reactions and it's
not easy if she finds night before
that's a big if which we will be waiting
on pins and needles for but first let's
take our first caller today welcome to
the show let us know your name and where
you're calling from la I have a question
on the game between Carolina and her
lonely when I'm looking on the chest 24
it doesn't only hides but two minutes so
do you think you can find that takes
before with only about two or three
minutes left in the game
Wow thank you for your call first of all
the time pressure often you know Reds a
player up he starts seeing in
calculating very very very rapidly right
as a player up I see what you did there
yeah that's a player player up yes well
so don't put it past any of these
competitors they calculate very very
very well and especially when they're
forced to there's desperation in lavon's
position and so to the caller's question
the answer is yes McCann but he's not
likely through its lesson it's gotta be
first of all the times might not be
exactly accurate on chess 24 there are
some issues with the main site has the
exact accurate time okay once in chess
24 or I don't think roughly correct but
they might not be exact okay and you see
them kind of flip around once in a while
but that being said I I I would say that
the chances of fine Knight takes before
are lower with less time they're
definitely not zero but if you had to
put a percentage on it as the problem is
it's even for the best players like
yourself isn't it a little bit difficult
to unsee you move once you've seen it
and then it's hard to evaluate how
difficult it is to see the move yeah
sometimes you do have these blind spots
right I mean you had a very very
specific focus that what you are trying
to achieve an ith 3:9 a f4 and then
you've got it reverse yourself right and
because you don't have that luxury of
time you usually are staying on the same
horse that got you into the situation to
begin with so yes but then again I just
feel that when you get to this position
and realize so many things don't work
you start right you know scrambling
right and trying to find something so
what would you put it out you know the
big rage in sports betting in the last
couple years has been live odds so
instead of betting like before the game
a lot of times you're betting about
outcomes in the middle of the game as
it's happening right so if you had to
put a line on whether he will find night
takes before right now would you say
5050 would you bet against 2 1 again I
would probably go with the 50/50 because
the e5e for alternative is also
attractive yeah but LaVon you know ok
you sweat you said his forums not that
good but you know he's desperate to play
a very good game and on any given game
of course he could turn it around
that's a there was a rest day yesterday
that's something that can turn your form
around starting out with flip-flopping
wins in round 3 and 4 loss to kramnik
win to car yakin he's lost a lot of
games since then including two to the
Americans Wesley so and Fabiano Karen
and back to back round six and seven
kind of the reverse of his Sinquefield
Cup victory a few years ago where he was
that the Slayer of the Americans yes
he's doing terribly against the
Americans and is are those what was
going to increase in round 13 and 14 or
is he going to come out of this game
with a drawl Irwin aye it's all about
this this move doesn't find it Murray
exactly by the way this position is an
incredibly important moment because if
you look at this Queen f6 we're starting
the analysis with this move Queen f6
King takes on h4 and now this move Queen
check and now your King is under heavy
fire came to f1 and the engines giving
Knight d4 this time with the idea being
to take with the rook yet again and here
comes rook a for work f4 excuse me
screeching into the position and this
King under heavy fire completely
stripped of any protection this position
is just winning for black as these
pieces are irrelevant to what's going on
against this King right now
so this line looks pretty good now the
other point is that that if you if I
force you to take with the King your
kings in trouble right the problem here
the problem is back here queen up excuse
me Queen f6 you're not going to take
with the king you're going to take with
the Queen
so LaVon may have been thinking okay
what if I check instead so that I force
you to take with the king and then I
play Queen f6 now your King is stuck and
here comes Queen h4 the problem is who
gave white a free move and now White has
the very simple rook h1 stopping that
completely and now he's going to come
get help from everybody Queens gonna
land on f3 in fact even hear the engines
giving the move Knight to d4 84-84 as
cd44 as a move and now getting the king
out of danger in this position and it's
not so easy to just move your queen
because this check is happening and at
the moment black looks still like he
might generate an attack well that's
certainly a dangerous King but white is
for choice here
so this tricky position is for LaVon to
analyze do I play the check to force the
King over but then I let Rick h1 happen
or do I wait and then the Queen will
capture and then it doesn't work anymore
because the Queen is there and the King
is just slides back either to F f1 or h3
and protects that entire side so this is
what he spends out a lot of time on
wondering should he check or should he
play Queen f6 in the position and I
believe we have a move in the game it
looks like after he played the move
Queen f6
that spent a long time on that move and
I think just for that reason the idea
should I check first or should I play
Queen f6 which also shows something else
guys the fact that he spent so much time
to me means that he is an intuitive mode
is you know when you're in bad form
usually your calculation is off you're
looking at specific moves you're missing
moves the brains not quite working in
the calculation your intuition might
because you're kind of flowing and maybe
even your intuition could be a little
off but usually you're the brains that's
not doing what it's supposed to do and
you're not seeing the moves like you
would normally do so his intuition might
be ok but if he doesn't see concrete
moves and they're not calculating well
then you'll just miss the winning lines
it would be sad for Fabi if today from
that good position that he had if now
lavon's brain starts working really well
and then suddenly you see his sacrifice
is happening and in this line Queen f2
it is the moment to play this move
Knight takes b4 which requires a
combination of calculation but very
importantly into
in here as well because you've got to
feel like looking at this board hey
buddy you're up to pieces but these
offside guys are not going to be able to
deal with my attack it's a very
intuitive analysis given that yours down
so much material will he go with that
intuition slash calculation slash guess
frankly and go for this line genius idea
very very difficult with the time
pressure just this is a very difficult
move to fire yeah Knight takes before
well again the gist it's just one of
those positions where you recognize that
your material down that if you give
white literally that one tempo to play a
move like rook h1 you you're lost so you
have to find night text before but we do
have brick breaking news from Maurice
Maurice actually did not find night
takes before LaVon not in that kind of
scintillating shape that he was in
earlier in 2017 when he was tearing up
the tournament circuit just a bit off
and now instead of doing that after
Queen f2 he played he for a logical move
trying to bring his knight into the game
and also attacking on that square that
is not what the doctor ordered in this
position
efore again more intuition than
calculation you got to bring it all
together though when you're playing
great chess at this level and this will
be four changes the whole fabric of the
position white now has choices including
just simply snapping this pawn off and
bringing his bishop into the game the
game has changed dramatically guys and
Fabiano fans can breathe a sigh of
relief but only for a moment there's
build dynamic chance to deal with this
king right this is a wild position and
if time pressure starts bearing hold
Bobby will get in some kind of troubles
but man it when somebody tells probably
night before was on the board he's good
he's either gonna wet his pants or if he
wins the game you say oh thank God that
didn't happen
exactly right now though efore on the
board well 15 minutes left in the time
control so there's got to be some time
pretty sure with eight moves left for
both of them to make yeah and it's still
a very sharp position ePHI before it's a
very human move because again just as
you're describing it Maurice this knight
on c6 really once get in the game he
just simply didn't realize that Knight
takes before was on tap he's looking at
an opportunity to play 95 but he's also
looking at an opportunity to play Queen
takes c3 and maybe in that case the
knight can use the d4 square so ePHI
before I fully understand that move
that's move that you would probably find
in blitz and you would miss this great
opportunity that you've been describing
Knight takes before and by the way I
still hadn't found a good answer tonight
takes before I know the computer was
going zero zero zero but I was looking
for an advantage I didn't find it for
white after Knight takes before and I
couldn't find an advantage for white in
fact I was starting to think oh pretty
pretty wild I mean there's a lot of
options here for Fabi you looked at
Queen f4 what about the snapping the
pawn off also very logical before you
can't move the Queen now because I've
have six jacks type stuff yes oh that's
a dream if you could never get in f5 f6
things are really going in your favor
now let's see what can we do on black
side well let's say he loses night just
for argument's sake now how do we
untangle our King and make things
difficult ninety-four something like
thank you for I will have Knight takes
d4 Bishop f2 Knight f6 and I picked up
with the check yeah yeah no I'm I'm more
on the 93 rook g8 track than I am on the
on the immediate Knight g4 Bishop takes
e4 looks really good but again I'm not
really too sure why did we reject
we are I think we were I think we were
worried about Queen takes c3 we like
this after Queen c3 to be find a move
your like work h1 well exact rook GA
check I can dance away with my King King
f1 I'm eyeballing this opportunity for
Queen takes h6
works eight-six so Bishop takes c3
doesn't help mine I mean yeah this just
looks I mean with no more checks this is
just got to be winning for for White
Queen takes c3 rook takes h6 check right
or should we just take it if we take a
timeout with Bishop takes a three you
take my work with checks so that's kind
of annoying right
precisely although I don't know maybe
that's okay too also check you got a
look at a lot of because even they are
Bishop do you think three Bishop takes
c3 Queen a1 bishop c1 and I'm wondering
if you can actually stop the me on h6
anyway that point on f5 does it such a
great job stopping the rook from coming
to g65 of course just simply loses to
Queen takes g5 yeah but I do have the
very very very long retreating move oh
no wreck a cage this is just winter ring
against one yeah so how about check
instead though I've got it a check now
if you move your king - f - you're
dropping this bishop with a check so you
have to play King to e1 and I'll give
you another check and then I transpose
it that same line oh no Bishop d2
well isn't this where we just came from
after bishops you want
oh no no no because you have Queen C for
each other that's a nice way of covering
up and Queen's reject that didn't help
you at all if you tried to trade Queens
that was not gonna help because against
those bishops the end of the day we're
just taking on eight six anyway yeah
everything right we can't
afford the trade of queens because c6
night is also everything's is going
right I mean you do a rookie one but it
doesn't yeah right
whoa whoa whoa so actually it's one of
those positions where white suddenly has
options Maurice Bishop takes e4 Queen f4
maybe even my rook rook h1 whereas
before after the move Knight takes
before he we didn't have the options
he's currently as of all the options
what does the engine reckon is fab E's
best choice they're different moves for
Fabi right now and taking on e4 was one
taking on b5 danger doesn't believe
blacks attack anymore
this is busted I want to go back to this
line with Knight yes please before C
takes b4 and rook takes d4 and I was
wondering what could have given them on
pause in this moment like what may he
have seen that made him back up here
there is this possibility of the move
Bishop to b2 simple development now why
is this a move because if you play rook
f4 now something you run into Queen f4
and the bishop is awake and so that
attack doesn't work that well and but
here is the line that he might have
missed Queen g5 check looks like it's
making some kind of progress Queen to g3
and suddenly everybody is kind of
protecting each other and you're looking
good
but then comes this move rook to d2
check and because this Bishop is under
attack
this Knight is the only thing defending
it this is not easy for white King I
mean yes it's some King f3 and now in
this fight take a look at the craziness
that could happen Queen to h5 check and
he has to be very careful does white in
this position I remember there's always
Bishop e3 doesn't always work c2 can you
believe the engine gives King e4 as
triple zero steel before now I was
giving black a slight advantage of
course walking into his line and
nobody's gonna do but it just shows that
he really had a chance here he might
have might that might have been what he
missed I don't know we won't know until
the press conference and he could have
had this position but but he did have
that Bishop to be
- Queen g5 and white still cannot cover
up and that was the most important thing
about the position that Queen g3 didn't
help because the D 2 square is no longer
protected it's double defended now my
Bishop b2 it looks like it's still not
there and after this Queen then this
move so Bishop to b2 doesn't work and
also by the way rook takes b4 is a move
the engine gives just boldly just taking
more material and attacking the bishop
and saying I don't care I still have a
great position so a couple of options
for him this would have been very strong
to play this way but he did not he
played the move efore in the game and it
looks like we do have a move rook to h1
on the board white now dominating on
this side very difficult for black to
break through in this position and they
think about the position as well is in
an old Petrosian statement if you
sacrifice material players though you
sacrifice not like you lost it and here
LaVon stayed conservative he sacrificed
the piece and maintained his three pawns
so he can at least say in this position
I'm even material but sorry you're
busted he had to keep in that
sacrificial vein an ultra sacrificial of
nine takes before this one he kept his
material played without that real Alon
and now he's in deep trouble Wow well I
really like this move bro h1 very much
because again it just fits with both
players mauling one another's king
yeah I'm just see that Knight g4 the
bishop on on c1 and the Queen on f6 a
lot of things going fab ease way in this
line sorry everything is just coming
into the game for Fabiano and you know
it's just like even though his King I
it's never got into pure safety in this
game there's legacy variations where it
just lands on f1 and without a light
squared Bishop for for black there's
just no way to target it to disturb yeah
meanwhile for everything but the work on
I want is just coordinating perfectly
for Fabiana right the bishop once you
want the bishop on c2 is turning that
black Queen on f6 into a glorified
bishop yes blockading but not do
anything and if you if you do play queen
takes c3 with the idea that you're gonna
get your knight into the game after move
like rook a3 that might even have been
rook h6 check by the way I like this
idea of rook a3 where the rook could
actually you know swing across to the
king site and just scorch the black king
as well so then everybody is in in the
attack was perfect though by the way I
saw your instincts yeah green leaves
then you get shot on the other side
exactly so you can look at that line yes
beautiful variation effect Queen takes
c3 actually just just walks into rook
takes it to this check and the nice line
is after King takes the move
f6 tell them the king you are never ever
ever going anywhere as we stream at you
check as the bishop appears on e4 and
you just get blown off the board by
those incredible pieces that White's
about the drop on that side Wow meeting
attack with attack yeah that you got a
bad on the board
exactly it's like those bright
commercials where they're in central
part two players are having a game and
it's sort of like would you like a
sprite and check check you know like
that's the way they do it this you're
saying that happens more often in
commercials and it happens in real life
that's right that's exactly what I'm
saying okay so let's just have some fun
with this let's go over to Maurice we've
got some insights what's going on
well we have some breaking news that's
gonna also shake up the entire
tournament standings as well in this
position remember a long time ago I said
something about a pawn on e5 that's act
I just I just floated the only way to
get rid of that Knight is a pawn on e5
well check this out a 6 but we were back
here paying attention to a snoozefest
draw actually back here we felt it was a
drug although again it's the only thing
to do is to eject Knights Knights love
stable squares and when I looked at the
night I said okay the night has to be
ejected somehow and the only way to do
it is to play this move well Bishop c6
happened Queen a5 Queen c5 a 6
everything okay so far efore and now 80
HP 580 HP five and then this way to move
get into 87 and here it is ejecting the
night off that square and the most
natural move is to put the night on the
f5 square and then everything's okay
instead he played this move Knight takes
on B line Oh
what Knight takes on b5 his point is if
you play Bishop takes he's looking to
play moves like c2 because your pin the
inch is actually even given the quiet e6
a nod and saying even this position
white cannot win because the pin is too
strong and this is gonna happen it's
quitting on a dark square so the bishop
can never come back to help and the pin
just last but instead he missed this
power move e6 and this changes the whole
game is not as king is being stripped of
all its defenses and he's gonna drop
this night if he has to bring his queen
back to defend under now he simply under
duress what is he supposed to do about
this move he's about to lose a piece in
this line and it looks like he has
actually even given up the piece in the
main line it looks like we do have a
couple of moves on the board let's see
he takes the deflate
anybody see to first look inviting to
play this move and then played well that
can't be right
it had to have turned no sorry the move
went differently it looks like he played
after each six he played this move first
and now this one right and we do I
believe have well looking at this
position he's about to get a queen but
what if this guy tries to get a queen
first sharp line let's take a look at
this came to g7 we'll be careful that
you don't lose this joker right in some
position so what's happening here
exactly so anyway you're saying we don't
haven't made any way with just making a
queen so Queen b8 Murray's b8 hold on
I'm gonna try to well I've got Bishop d5
check in Queen c7 check that can all
but don't I have more there can I check
you on e8 perhaps and try to checkmate
you check me we're here like we need a
check yeah but that's your last check
isn't it yeah I'm gonna ship to d5 and
now that I've got a checkmate a threats
movie six looks forced to bring the
manual that's a nice defense over the f8
squared but this looks it sure looks a
square is guarded so this takes now he
can Queen and no I don't have any you
don't and you don't have any cheat you
this check is gonna march this way right
and and this check go back this check
you're gonna march that way and there's
no check exactly exactly
whoa okay this game just got crazy so
what would happen if after takes on f7
you just made a queen what was the lie
on that so c2 let's take a look on your
board guys okay sure
let me bring this one up now and if
mommy darling - so so meaningful so we
do have I think that II six move is a
real zinger something that may be right
under Grisha commands for sure and we
have C 2 we have takes and this is the
current situation so if you had made a
queen would we make a knight or a queen
can we can we check mate you if we make
a knight I'm just looking at that line
you mean just even for me if instead of
King g7 you play so you play make a
queen Queen Queen you mean something
like this well this is for Queen right
mate or should we make a queen I go for
the Queen just a second alone you just
go for the Queen just a second you don't
have any why would this be checkmate
yeah you're saying you can just go can
you just can you like an even movie move
my knight it's like I don't
this is really weird yeah man anyway
lean and then there's no checks for
there's no real there's actually not
that many checks for black check the
light square bishop covers everything
exactly okay so that was my black late
King g7 King g7 and back over to you
Maurice
well we have breaking news the game is
over
ym is over Grisha has resigned a
brilliant finish actually by Madeira and
now he has left into a tie for first at
the moment with with Kuryakin he needed
this win desperately Richards chances of
winning the tournament have now
officially ended he has no way to win
anymore so his game against Carr Yakka
game against Bobby tomorrow will loom
quite large as he just simply has no way
to win any more mighty try to play
spoiler so that his fellow Russian car
yakin will have a great chance to win
the tournament we will see but at the
moment Richards tournament is officially
over
while my Madeira at seven and a half and
the reason why I'm saying that is
because of this head-to-head matchup
even if we shook one tomorrow remember
zero I've lost he would have seven and a
half but he would lose a tie-break to my
Madeira off himself so that is just a
done deal for him he has no way to
somehow wind and we were even not even
talking about the result of fabi's game
that would have a big impact on that as
well but this position guys this game is
over after King to g7 they were actually
multiple wins but I think he found the
most beautiful one he played the move
Bishop to e4 attacking this pawn getting
threatening to get rid of it Queens
happen on the board to Queens on the
board allowing the two queens and now
suddenly this move Queen to d8 monster
move
threatening simply Queen g8 excuse me
grating to simply Queen and also
threatening Queen g8 and Queens no
matter what you do you're going to lose
a piece at least in this line cuz you're
gonna have to ditch your Queen and I say
a piece I mean one of these babies
you're gonna have to ditch at least a
queen if you can get that line itself
because you can control this square this
game is over
there's nothing
do about the double threat of Queens
manufacture guard the square there are
no checks for you so the only way to
guard it is something like e six but he
does have this move Queen to g8 to start
Oh actually just notice something else
you can actually even Queen in this
position and made into let's go to
getting myself a queen and after Queen
takes Queen takes and mate on the board
beautiful finish oh that was but let's
ask me let's go back to her of tied for
the lead but climbing I know Carolina's
game looks like it's just about to end
yes as they approach the time control
and Fabiano seems to be actually
encroaching on black so let's pop in on
that game the last time we saw it play
no more appointment of many more moves
are played and finally I know it looks
like he's really finishing off in style
yes that's when we check into it it was
I think rook h1 has been played since
then yeah h1 we really like this move
because of the counter chances against
upon on h6 then saw this move d6 now he
takes the pawn on either re takes on e4
whoops g8 our king and now slides into
f1 where there's no way very very okay
95 Queen F were piling up on h6 we don't
and now I have that on the screen do we
go oh yeah we need to get this in the
spring are we understanding so okay we
need to get this game down analysis
because that game is amazing it looks
like that game is going to end any
moment now because there's have been a
fantastic move and we have breaking news
in the Fabiano carolina game Fabiano was
able to sacrifice on h6 like we saw in
so many against Levon Aronian and now
he's in the clear lead at the camera
wonderful Wow three three wins in the
penultimate round what a way for these
players to rise to the occasion
oh my wins and there's still one game
pending two wins to win sweet oh it was
a tries wrong Wesley who is Wesley in
kuryakin's I misspoke two wins but look
what wins Wow big tacular at the top
just simply a
amazing to see and there's Fabi at
number one in the tournament right now
back with eight points and I see we got
his rating in there as well that matters
but he's got eight seven and a half
seven and a half
ding Lauren praying and praying that he
doesn't get officially knocked out of
the event although he may have with that
Fabi win I think he's also done yes he
is done
ding Lauren is finished if he does not
win this game if he only makes a draw
and it looked like he was struggling to
save the position but if ding Lauren
only makes the draw so he's not quite
finished yet he somehow wins the game
against chronic he's still in the mix
Bobby did it let's make it a finish
absolutely well we have left it way back
here after this move e5 e for and that
seems to be the blunder we've been
talking about Knight takes b4 as an
amazing move that may have turned the
tables in lavon's favor but after E for
rook h1 rook d6 now Bishop takes e4 rope
GA check King F 1 now White's King
finally finding some safety Knight e5
Queen f4 piling up on this h6 pawn soon
as this Knight moves keep in mind that
Bishop on c1 is also eyeballing the pawn
on h6 we saw c7 c6 Lucius um we should
stop there yeah seize notice now the
initiative is finished yes it's all
white now because sixes c6 is an
admission that he has no more aggressive
moves right and so now he played c6 she
said because 95 is on tap for white c7
c6 takes on b5 rook g5 again probably
time trouble is a big factor here the
Von's looking to plug up the diagonal c1
to h6
thank you very much give me a pawn and
by the way I've got a passed pawn to a7
and after Queen d8 Faby was just waiting
for this move f7 f 6 with a discovered
check getting at blacks King night drop
back to g6
this looks like the moment for the
diagram right I mean you have the
tactical puzzles how do you how do you
finish the game
well rook takes h6 check not a fair
puzzle I might add because after all
white is up a piece and a pawn in this
position this is one of those puzzles
you say why are you showing me this
position it's too easy that he's already
winning the game right but still how do
you cleanly finish him off fight so you
cannot move your King because the rook
will hang and I'm thinking after King
takes I've got this really cute check
just your turn how are you gonna get out
of this well you got to put your rook in
the way now I have discovered check this
time with my bishop and I can either
play I don't know just all kinds of
checks or energy of our I mean and your
winning back the whole world and you've
got a continued attack after for example
King G 897 check what a finish and what
was the finish was after resign amazing
Wow
so far we have three critical games
already finished today
5e an old heroine with eight points now
he's half a point ahead of his nearest
rivals with two with one round to go
Sergei car yakin and mommy Dhara
the heat is on them tomorrow one other
thing that's really actually helped
Fabiano is that alex green stuff went
down that means alex is not in a
must-win situation tomorrow with 1e
that's actually a huge boon I think for
Fabi I don't only what does that mean
that means that father's gonna try to
cruise we've seen too much by Christian
in this position - going for Fabi there
are 2 players chasing him and I believe
both have better tie breaks yeah both
that typewriter Sergey has a better tie
break head-to-head against him and also
my madear of no we have to go to the
third tie break in order to and I think
the third tiebreaker moment your rope is
better as well that's true so if either
Miami
or Sergei win and Fabia only drawls then
yes that could be probably so it don't
have to you know when I when you play
these tournaments you got to win them
you don't try to slide in no do what you
did today take the guy hit him and then
the other guy say come get me and let me
show you what I'm gonna do to you you've
got to have the right attitude and I
think that Fabi felt that as he was
trying to cruise a little bit earlier
and then one loss hit him and now he
woke up and thankfully woke up just in
time poor Aronian however poof huh Fabi
did dodge a bullet we're gonna talk
about all the greatness of this game but
Fabi did dodge a bullet and move Knight
takes it doesn't matter what's hard to
find
there's 2,800 players it was there but
even 2,800 there was chaos on the board
and they only had like 5-10 minutes he
is great expect to see you every single
variation granted granted that is true
that is true but when we're talking
about pure chess on the part of the
player who wins you know you give
Flair's chances it means that you know
make a little hole in there and you got
to watch out tomorrow because Rick might
come to win as well you know country man
yes it will help his countryman Sergei
carjacking if he wins but it's not
helping him anymore he's still out of
the party no matter what yes could it be
bad for Fabi that Grisha cos less
determined it would be bad if one of his
rivals wins and beats him on tiebreak or
it could be good if they both draw so we
could don't know well I'm with you all
the way I I don't want to play somebody
so motivated to beat me they win first
place because then they're playing to
their kings right so Griffiths
tournaments over
that'll take a lot of wind out of his
sails but Fabiano come on he's in pole
position let's look at this though let's
look at this guy's Chris Chuck we know
he's a poker player he's a little on the
crazy side might just say what you know
what soccer players should have to lose
tomorrow by going after Bobby what does
he have to lose nothing if you win
the game draws the game whatever it
doesn't matter to him so I don't know it
looks to me like Richard might come in
with the attitude tomorrow oh whatever
and plus he's gonna get a few phone
calls from Moscow
excuse you you better go after this guy
tried to kill him thank you and good
luck we'll be motivated in but there
might even be a little bit of money
under the table go after Fabi go
laughter Fabi little know that right
even if he only makes a draw let's talk
car yakin do you really want to test car
yeah can skill at winning with the white
pieces if he needs to in the last round
that is not what you want he'll be
facing off against ding Lorraine
tomorrow
now thing is the only player in the
competition that has not lost a single
game the only player now we need them to
channel his inner dignity but it's more
and not and lose that game tomorrow and
that's gonna be a very big matchup and
remember 0 vs kramnik let's point that
out crumb dick he goes whole hog and you
know crime nick is gonna go for it
tomorrow as well against my medir office
to try to make sure he my Madeira off
doesn't compete against his countrymen
because bombers Europe has better tight
breaks against car yak it is well having
exacting him in round one right so
grounding both chronic and Christian are
motivated if only for the Olympic team
member to say let's go take these guys
down and make cardiac in the Challenger
once again they'll probably get a job on
top if they do Sergei is buying no
question yeah I mean that's it is gonna
be interesting to see how hard watching
fights tomorrow but you know he has
nothing to lose as Murray said I mean
there's nothing left in the tort of it
so why not go for it and just show your
best chest tomorrow let's just take a
look at the game that is still pending
it's the game between ding Gloria and
Vladimir Kramnik that game has been very
topsy-turvy affair essentially it's been
two minor pieces versus a rook in favor
of Vladimir Kramnik for quite some time
and Vladimir has just played this move
knight on e4 to g5
with a check you don't want to what this
is actually a pretty funny
mating pattern not one that you see
every day the night protects f3 and h3
pawn on g3 and it will be checkmate
after rook c4 rook takes e4 so oops
excuse me that was a mouse lit rook
takes c4 check and mate
so that means that ding has to slip back
with this king to do 2 which walks into
a rook takes a to check King F 1 now
it's only one pond and a rook versus two
minor pieces but there are some really
mating patterns once that Knight gets to
f3 if if the black could put a knight on
f3 as well as a bishop on d4 then it's a
very easy check mating pattern with rook
f2 so I think that ding is really
fighting for his life here how do you
play
how do i how do I come after king
everyone yeah what are you doing f1 what
do you do with black you're saying he's
fighting for his life the reality is
you're just described the mating idea
right is he able to get rid of the b6
pawn you won't have a soul fight one
night f3 attacking the rook Ruby
forecheck rook g4 check and let's say I
don't know it came here I got it I got a
tricky check he's gonna move his rook of
course - well you've also got rook c6
check so you could force me to start it
there yeah yeah I mean right okay in
King h7 ok and now look here perhaps
rook F or just get a get out of that
fork for a second that's annoying
you get one check but what do you get
you can't with your bishop you can't get
to d4 this well how does this go Maurice
agate you said I got one check well let
me play it if you play King g1 I was
actually thinking about a check yeah
let's not fall for trees but even here
your king is remarkably safe I can't hit
that yeah isn't that surprising or maybe
I was a little bit too optimistic for
the two pieces go back again though
let's look at this
King f1 alright and then night of three
rook g4 check why did you go to H well I
couldn't come to the F file no I think
on the F file there's a rook f4 check
and I dropped my now of course but what
about working eight seven record
immediately and no way there's no rook
c6 right and then the same variation
that knight on f3 is too powerful or got
to kick the night out so how would this
affect things the thing there in that is
no I think he's out he would have to
have a break even if Bobby loses he'll
end up that is probably somewhat good
for Fabiano Carolina cuz if he knows he
can't win no matter what happens he
might not play as slashing chess with
black pieces against Sergei Kuryakin
exact and Sergei knows that he's up
against it he needs to try to win that
final round game he's not gonna sit
there hoping Bobby loses yeah it's gonna
try to win and yeah and his score you
know you always I like the way you paint
the positive spin hi Bobby
what I was right about you know him
having his chances to kill Sergei of
London learn to sit there and try to
hope and pray for a draw because if he
does that then he only has two results
while Sergei is coming in there with
that good old Russian squeeze and we
know Sergei is a man who likes to win
wind up when the chips are down so I
don't trust anything about this kind of
spin that dig Lorraine is not gonna play
for anything we don't want to depress
sting Lorraine that's the last thing you
need tomorrow
you do want to tap to like feel like he
should be able to play at least and and
if he ties potti
hey great if he loses
anyway oh you you one thing to be
motivated to take down car yeah key
because the Yak is the man that's the
real danger
Kuryakin wins and you only make a draw
bye bye
chances are out for the sort of the
matchup and how would that work
Maurice happy drawers yay he goes into
the clubhouse Sergey drawers yeah he's
not a contender but Shaq could win
that's it it's over Fabi oh well it's
not the first two tiebreaks first tie
break is head to head they join both
their games second tie break number of
wins they will have the same number of
wins in that situation
third tie break Sonnenberg burger
sonamoo burger that one is a problem for
Fabi because mama Dee rob has defeated
the higher better for starters Sergey
cognac in and that's where fabi's in
trouble because I was shocked that big
number of him defeating right
oh and he'd be greased Rick today more
points him Bobby defeated Aronian twice
that really does not help him at all
that's terrible for him in fact it's
because he beat the player last and then
so as well and maybe Wesley as well so
this is not helping him in any way it is
he doesn't want to see that draw in the
clubhouse will be one of those biting
your fingernails jaws because he's gonna
have to pray that neither one of those
players win their games or else he's
just out on the spot like that right but
I don't think we took will have any
extra incentives in the game like
financially because I would kind of be
cheating I mean you can't give you can't
give somebody a bonus for beating
somebody at the end of the tournament
like that wouldn't be fair yeah that's
right yes amazing result great great
game by fabulous go to a commercial
break and we'll come back to gather our
thoughts and share them for this amazing
round 13 of the candidates
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it Bosch
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today and
Jesse Arthur we certainly got off to a
great start today with Bob piano
Carolina winning his game giving him the
pole position here with one round to go
in the candidates absolutely fantastic
result for American chess fans and boy
he had his on the edge of our seats in a
really really complex game but he did
get the best of liván and as you say he
leads the tournament half a point with
one round to go and amazing
possibilities for this final round
coming up tomorrow
normally this 1/2 point lead would be so
massive yasser because it would be you
know give him a good chance of winning
clear and worse not worst case scenario
but very likely scenario he would tie
for first if somebody else won and he
drew and there would be a playoff so at
least he had a good chance to win that
way but not the case here no the rub is
that if he does go into the clubhouse
with let's say draw and if he were to be
caught he does lose tiebreaks exactly so
normally we would say here like Bobby's
perhaps like 75 80 percent to become the
Challenger instead I would put it like
60 ish just because the fact of those
scenarios were somebody else catches him
right and he doesn't get it well as to
Nero's rifles Shaq and Sergei are so
motivated it's hard not to see one of
them winning their final round game you
don't think one of them you think that
it's more likely that one of them will
win yes they're not that's right oh wow
but we'll see Maurice over to you your
thoughts well we are having arguments in
here all grandmasters trying to figure
out the scenarios and our colleagues
Alejandra Ramirez and also Christian
korilla they're saying that Fabi should
just take the drawer and go into the
clubhouse and sweat it out that's their
philosophy and they're also saying okay
obviously if Fisher gives them some
chances you want to fight it out and and
but be careful because you want to lose
the game you're not gonna go all out and
take chances
but if it's Gris Chuck Grichuk has no
motivation anymore he is absolutely out
of the chances out of the
right now no matter what he does he
cannot possibly win by virtue of having
lost to two Grizz chick having lost to
manager off today and also because Fabi
just has too big a score so that's the
end of that so Grizz shook with no
motivation will he just simply play some
limp variation go for a draw walk out in
there Fabi gets to eight and a half and
make everybody wonder what's gonna
happen in those other two games now we
can start debating what's going to
happen tomorrow because there's also
critical pairings really huge shoes
pairs in yeah so you're saying that
about 50% better than 50% well in the
game I'm a Jeremy's black against
kramnik I'm not sure you would give that
one a better chance from a Madeira of
but certainly Kuryakin against Dean
we've seen car yeah can win when he
needed to he took down Fabiano Carolina
when he needed to why can't he take down
ding exactly we have a special guest on
a telephone call Jenna that's right
welcome to the show I know you know we
didn't have a hat we didn't get a chance
to have a chest lesson today I told him
you had to watch the game and it was
quite a game to watch welcome to the
show our founder here of the st. Louis
chess club Rex Sinquefield
you guys are too kind I don't know why
you take my call on the joint just
watching the three greatest commentators
in the world and you interrupt that
accepting my phone call Oh bless you my
dear madam else you can truly be
forgiven anyway everybody in Central
Missouri is celebrating the Fiddler's
are out the cows and goats are jumping
in the field I'll tell you there's just
grand jubilation but unfortunately it's
laced with anxiety because who knows
what's going to happen tomorrow
Yaser I think back to a similar
situation in 1971 and 72 and I watched
the way Bobby Fischer marched through
the candidates Tama gnostics to know
Larsen's things to know Petrosian six
and a half two and a half there's
nothing like that this year is there Rex
which is precisely that in a sense all
draws tomorrow the Challenger in this
case Bobby he's kind of backed his way
and you losing a game at the very end
and it's not like we came into today
saying there was a maybe five persons
who could become challenger when Bobby
Fischer stormed his way through the
candidates Rex just as you were saying
everybody saying uh that's the guy
that's the guy who's the legit rightful
Challenger and tomorrow it could be you
know three persons all becoming the
Challenger and saying hey they got lucky
well I I think that if he wins tomorrow
oh if he wins - really changes the
complexion of his challenge is being
challenger that all except yes if he
tries tomorrow becomes the Challenger
especially after getting so close to
also qualifying two years ago I believe
that um everybody will say this match
magnetars Fabiano this is what we want
to see right now but we do have another
special guest Thank You Rex for calling
in and watching the games studying
writing notes to for the call with very
very poetically said actually Bandemer
an invoice for the chess lesson or I
just want to see the analysis the the
night takes before Rex is like hammered
analysis exactly we have another special
gas we have the head of curator over at
the world chess Hall of Fame so busy
they're actually about to put up three
new shows so took a break from putting
all that together to chat with us indeed
we have chief curator I believe is the
official title
Shannon Bailey with me and if you wanna
if family does win we should point out
that
Fabiano Caruana will be here for the
u.s. championship in two weeks you'll
have to take a break and play the
Greinke classic these guys are so busy
it's incredible but he will be here and
if you come to see Fabi battle it with
battle it out with Wesley and the Canuck
more and the rest of the crew Jeffrey
Zhang and the like then you will
definitely also want to go over to the
world chess Hall of Fame where they just
put up great shows Shannon you had great
shows that you're taking you just took
down I know you have the fashion exhibit
as well and really we're taking them
down as we speak
incredible and tell us about these three
new shows that you're bringing up well
I'm really excited to be partnering with
pearling London the luxury chess set
companies and this will be our first big
collaboration we've exhibited a couple
of their artists in the past so we have
an exhibition called painted pieces and
it's going to feature 20 artists you can
see this great kind of collage of the
the King piece they've got beautiful yes
and what's great is that Q boutique was
the first US retailer of their work and
now they've expanded but you'll be able
to buy some of these sets during the run
of the show and plus like playing cards
and backgammon and checkers well look at
all those sensing incredible yeah
colors and styles they make some
wonderful said there were sponsors a
millionaire chess yes we ran that coat
they also contributed there but
incredible should be used yeah and one
thing that's really super fun about this
show is in addition to the 20 amazing
artists that are contributing we're
gonna for virtual reality stations where
you can play virtual reality chests and
we've all been trying it out and it's
amazing yeah you can play like in
different kinds of museums all
throughout the world or you complained
Gomorrah and you're playing against the
devil or the Grim Reaper or somebody but
it's a skeleton and my fire comes out of
his I feel like I might have nightmares
yeah and then on floor two this is a
very chess set heavy kind of round of
shows we're looking at the whole history
of the start and chess sets so we'll
have original pieces from the night
1840s up until a modern day GGG tea set
and we've got a very special unveiling
that we've taken place April 12th and
that exhibition as well and we'll have a
lot of loans from John crumb Miller and
Frank camerado and a few others so the
greatest collections in the world
absolutely and then floor three is
called the sink field effect the
resurgence of American chess and that is
celebrating the 10 years of
the st. Louis chess club and stainless
who's that guy Singh field Rack City
madam so we're really excited all of
that is April 12th we have another
really special unveiling that'll be
taking place that night as well so we
hope anybody that's local can come down
and visit hold on a second
i I'm getting kicked out of here after
this sort of man is over and and then I
come April 16th to come for the US
Championship and I know yeah so sooner
one's going to be in town as a Grand
Master in residence he's going to get to
have all this good stuff this is
terrible okay alright yeah so you always
get the good stuff
and so everyone absolutely great shows
on top and I will be here to take in
those when I get back of course in the
World Chess Hall of Fame they're always
doing innovative things virtual reality
I definitely have to come for that
Shannon Bailey the truth chief curator
of the world chess Hall of Fame
always doing wonderful work Thank You
Maurice and Thank You Shannon for all
the good work you do but jennifer we've
got some breaking news in that's right
that game between ding Lauren and
Vladimir Kramnik was a hard-fought draw
so we have all of our results in for the
the final round
Yaser and what a finale we have said
it's very exciting for American pants
because our player Fabiano Carolina is
at the top of the standings and you know
Shannon came in here and talk about the
show the C field effect to celebrate the
contributions of dr. Jeanne and Rex
Sinquefield but I mean what bigger
contribution could there be to celebrate
that show opening that having Fabiano as
the challenger to magnus carlsen cuz
that does really culminate many of their
efforts you know Fabiano lives here in
st. louis he had so many chances to
improve his game including of course the
the situating Sinquefield Cup where he
went seven all right so he's drink him
becoming the challenge which i think
would really be the crown jewel to that
show will it happen we're gonna find out
tomorrow
well it's a culmination everything
Rex and Jeanne have been striving for
cultivating a challenger to the World
Championship and this will be the first
American Challenger since 1996 and data
Kamsky yes you're more pessimistic than
I am you think that there's a 50 over 50
percent chance that either
mommy-daughter of our cardiac and will
win in this must-win situation I was
thinking more like 40 right don't put
Bobby as a favorite but I've played so
many tournaments and I remember one
specific tournament it was the New York
open that I was leading I had a half a
point lead and I took a quick draw in
the last round quote securing the the
draw and there was a chasing pack of
wolves and literally like ten players
were a half a point behind me and a
player would have to win to tie and sure
enough there was five games and there
were five decisive games like so
everybody tied with me for first I was
watching like prize money coming down
with each tie and you know when decisive
games are you know really really needed
you know the players go all out and
again why not it's first you know
there's only one one prize and that's
first so I'm pessimistic it's all or
nothing and your thoughts of tomorrow I
completely agree with you yes I could
you couldn't have said it better for me
as a Fabi fan well looking at Bobby as a
friend as well and and of course as an
American you want to see Fabi win but if
he draws you're just gonna be sitting
there praying because first of all if he
ties with Kuryakin
Kuryakin wins Huracan defeated them in
their head-to-head matchup and and then
that's it Bobby does not qualify he'll
be just looking at this tournament
having won in the second-to-last round
the penultimate round and saying up that
didn't help and if they're tied after
round 14 and memedia of draws Carano
wins I don't understand these if tied
after 14 a moment are
wins well obviously member zero has to
win there's no there's no chain right he
must win so he wins this game because of
the sudden burger system that's it he
has a better score why because he will
have defeated top players in order to
finish it up first of all he defeated
grishnack was a very nice score and he
has defeated car yakin who also has a
fabulous score card Khurana on the other
hand defeated Aronian twice and Aronian
is got only four points so getting his
score twice doesn't really mean much and
they both defeated Kramnik and so and so
that doesn't count so it's really the
matchup of car Khurana having defeated
Aronian twice being inferior to the fact
that by Madeira we'll have defeated both
Gris shook and one car yakun and those
two scores are fabulous scores and the
other tiebreaks are dead even
so Fabi kit is looking over his shoulder
he's absolutely looking over his
shoulder a draw yes
Grichuk decides I have two white pieces
I'm gonna shut things down I'm not gonna
play for anything there's gonna be hard
for Fabi to make anything with the black
pieces but it's that key matchup
first of all Vladimir Kramnik against my
metier of you know Vlade he comes to win
every single game so he's gonna go after
my Maduro in the last round just for fun
so mommy will look for his chances there
is that important matchup Sergei
Kuryakin with white you know he's got
the guts in the money rounds doesn't
fold he'll be going after ding Loren and
the only thing we can say is digging
hasn't lost in 13 tries will he make it
a smooth 14 and not lose yet again and
in that case I'll be on a car wanna will
cruise if mommy or Sergei doesn't win
the game you see the current standings
have been very very slim tangey was half
point lead by five yana by fabbi part
knee and really looking over
it's also by the way the theoretical
chance on this that ding wins the game
and ties Bobby but that doesn't help
dings tiebreaks will be worse than
properties because Bobby has won many
more games than he will he's a thing
right at won two games Bobby's already
won four games so he's not worried about
getting whatever ding does but if he
loses and Kuryakin and member zero both
draw then he loses in that case as well
so now he can't afford a loss pretty
much no Fabiano is not gonna win the
tournament with a loss but with a drawl
it's really up in the air I mean it's
probably close to 5050 if he if he draws
his final round game will he qualified
to play magnets 5050 we certainly would
have taken that a couple days ago yeah
after that brutal brutal round 12
oh absolutely no that was really really
terrible I mean it felt like a funeral
wake here and when have you lost that
round 12 that boy I always say you know
after a loss what do you do after a loss
right and that's a really is a Champions
you know returning with a victory that
that he did today and mom you know I by
the way they do yes that is a good point
I mean that's the mark of a champion it
is and they're both I mean really mom
and Aarav is also playing very well in
circuit Koryak and coming back for DN I
mean honestly any of these three players
would be very worthy challengers I think
they're joking yes
final thoughts for Maurice Ashley well
you gotta love it I mean the situation
is that we have Khurana in first place
he's got the black pieces the tension is
high remember when he was a bit cruising
trying to cruise a little bit before and
got that brutal loss against car yakin
but he came back like the champ knocked
out Aronian and now his destiny is
really in his hands if he goes for it if
he only draws then he's got two serious
horses chasing him what more could you
want is going to be a fabulous finish
and we'll be here to call it absolutely
right don't forget to tune in tomorrow
at 11:00 central that's 12 Eastern for
the final round of the candidates and we
will find out who's gonna play Magnus
Carlsen later this year in London
everything at stake as everything I say
well thank you very much for joining us
hope you'll join us tomorrow for today
in Ches
[Music]